INTENTIONAL AND HE IS NEVER
FAILING
♪
>> SHE LOST FANS, SHE LOST
FOLLOWERS, EVEN A POTENTIAL GIG
WITH FILM MAKER SPIKE LEE, HE
SP
POSTED ON INSTAGRAM, I WAS
THINKING ABOUT USING HER MUSIC
IN "SHE'S GOTTA HAVE IT."
CHRISETTE MICHELE IS WITH ME
NOW.
SHE JUST FINISHED A TRACK CALLED
"NO POLITICAL GENERAIUS."
>> THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> WHY DID YOU PERFORM?
>> THE DEMOCRATS DON'T RECEIVEN
S
-- EVEN SEE US THERE.
I SAW HIM ON TV AND THOUGHT HE
DOESN'T KNOW ME.
>> BECAUSE OF WHAT SPIKE LEE
SAID, WHAT WOULD YOU SAY?
>> YOU WERE SUPPOSED TO MENTOR
ME THROUGH THIS MOMENT, TAUGHT
US ART FOR CHANGE, THIS IS WHAT
THIS IS FOR, I WORE A -- SKIRT
ON THE STAGE OF THE INAUGURAL
BALL, WERE YOU NOT PAYING
ATTENTION?
AND THAT'S MY RESPONSE TO THAT.
>> THAT'S YOUR RESPONSE?
>> THAT'S IT.
IF WE'RE ARTISTS SUPPOSED TO BE
PEOPLE WHO SHAKE THE WORLD WITH
OUR ART THEN WE HAVE TO STAND AN
STAGE AND BE UNCOMFORTABLE.
I WAS SO EXCITED TO SHOW WHO WE
ARE AND WHAT WE'VE GOT TO SHOW
ON THAT STAGE.
>> WE TALKED ABOUT JENNIFER
HOLIDAY AND OTHER PEOPLE WHO
RECEIVED SUCH HATE THAT THEY
PULLED OUT.
>> BARACK OBAMA RECEIVED SUCH
HATE AND RAN AGAIN, SO I'M GOING
TO KEEP RUNNING JUST LIKE HE
DID.
AT THE END OF THE DAY EVERYBODY
IS GOING TO GET HATE FOR WHAT
THEY BELIEVE IN.
AND BLACK TWITTER IS NOT THE
ENTIRE BLACK AMERICA SO I REFUSE
TO MAKE 6,000 COMMENTS THE VOICE
OF BLACK AMERICA.
>> INDIA REA GAVE YOU LOVE.
>> I LOVE INDIA.
>> MY MOM AN DAD AND BROTHERS
WERE SUPER SUPPORTIVE BUT YOU
HAVE THOSE PETRIFIED OF POLITICS
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T MIX RELIGION
AND POLIPOLITICS.
>> FIRST OF ALL I SANG A GOSPEL
SONG.
>> WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO TRUMP
IF YOU WERE TO MEET HIM.
>> THIS IS WHAT WE LOOK LIKE.
AT THE END OF THE DAY HE HAS
CONSTITUENTS, FOLKS IN THE
CABINET, PEOPLE NOT THERE
ANYMORE AS NEWS JUST TOLD US.
I WANT HIM TO KNOW WHAT WE HAVE
TO SAY, WHAT WE THINK.
MY GOAL WITH ALL OF THIS IS TO
BRING THE STORY OF THE BLACK
GIRL WHO HAS A BABY IN HIS OWN
WELFARE WITH THE WHITE GIRL IN
SOUTH DAKOTA DAKTHAT HAS HER OW
STORY, IF I HAVE A COIN A PHRASE
"NO POLITICAL GENIUS" AND CREATE
A TV SHOW MYSELF SO OUR VOICE
CAN BE